jorick la 10e explique à nos
téléspectateurs comment le définir et
son son handicap alors déjà c'est un
handicap invisible pendant ses concerts
non parce que faut pas oublier qu'à 80%
des personnes qui sont en situation de
handicap non le handicap est invisible
donc là je suis sur votre plateau et
pour le monde des tonnes de
téléspectateurs qui vont nous dire ouais
n'avait pas handicapé elle n'est pas
autiste ça se voit pas ça se voit pas
pour plusieurs raisons c'est que le
spectre de l'autisme ma de l'autisme
sévère à l'autisme de haut niveau et que
je me suis filmé un tranchant autisme
haut niveau et autisme asperger on n'a
pas pu comme ça pendant des
dénominations et donc moi mon nautisme
se manifeste par un sens un déficit du
sens social c'est à dire que pour moi
des interactions sociales ne sont pas
faciles vous regarder dans les yeux
c'est pas facile de retrouver entourés
de gens c'est à dire très à l'aise c'est
pas facile mais parce qu'en fait ce jeu
comme beaucoup de femmes autistes et
adultes autistes et comme beaucoup de
femmes tout court j'ai beaucoup simulé
dans ma vie si vous dîtes ça pour vous
pour la journée le titre et non j'ai été
diagnostiquée très tardivement des jeux
c'est ça en fait j'avais entamé en 2012
mon processus de diagnostic et c'est
tellement long en fait en 2008 on est
diagnostiquée alors ça j'avais commencé
pour refaire un peu le trajet chez le
troisième de quatre enfants est la
neuvième de 45 cousin donc en fait j'ai
toujours été dans un environnement
finalement je faisais mon petit bonhomme
de chemin tout allait bien
j'étais trop j'étais joyeuse parade des
chantiers que vous avez senti qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui n'allait pas
d'accord en 2012 seulement depuis
toujours je me suis senti en décalage
mais voilà il ya plein de gens qui vous
diront surtout des ados qu'ils se
sentent en décalage pas compris pas
intégrer tous âges en savourant des
malheureux non parce que j'étais bien
que ma solitude en fait vous êtes bien
dans ma tête et je sais que j'ai donc
tout va bien je m'en sors bien avec moi
même j'ai beaucoup d'humour et on rit à
deux donc c'est très bien mais notre
entourage juste hummer est ce que vous
êtes quelqu'un vous passez alouettes je
suis marié avec deux enfants et est
votre conjoint quand il voulait jamais
plus parce que par ce côté très
fataliste je pense parce que je suis pas
dans les clous et parce que je ne sais
pas être dans les clous et même en
observant beaucoup en étant toujours à
essayer de m'adapter à faire comme les
autres où comme je pense que les autres
veulent que je fasse je suis toujours à
côté de la plaque quand il vos enfants
alors mes enfants c'est rigolo parce
qu'ils ont finalement ils ont 12 ans et
demi bientôt 17 ans et régulièrement je
tombe sur des publications facebook qui
date d'avant mon diagnostic où j'ai
surpris nu en train de parler de moi une
vision à maman tu trouves pas qu'elle
est elle est pas comme les autres maman
maman elle est allée bizarre ouais mais
c'est mieux parce que sinon les autres
mamans elles sont chiantes savent
accepter leur plaire ben en fait disons
que ça nous on est dans une année dans
une famille qui porte des valeurs
d'inclusion d'intégration
on aime tout le monde toutes les
couleurs toutes les origines on explique
à nos enfants que mes enfants je suis
fier d'eux quand ils me disent qu'ils
comprennent pas pourquoi il ya la manif
pour ton c'est que pourquoi deux hommes
ils pourraient pas se marier avoir des
enfants ensemble
il m'a je ne sais pas mon chéri c'est ça
donc en fait mené dans l'inclusion sur
depuis toujours j'ai des frères et
soeurs qui ont d'autres types de
handicaps invisibles également offert
qu'un diabète par exemple d'accord c'est
quand même un handicap jour rqth comme
moi mais voilà c'est bien une capeline
et il ya un jour où en 2012 je me suis
retrouvé en licenciement économique donc
beaucoup à la maison et là je me suis
senti un petit peu glissé à me dire que
j'étais tellement bien chez moi tout
seul et que finalement ça m'ennuyait
presque mon mari et mes enfants rentrent
à la maison parce qu'il y avait du bruit
y avait du mouvement paraît je parle
classe affaires projet maintient tout
seul et je me suis dit j'ai pas envie de
mettre mon couple en danger
enfin voilà on a jamais de crise de
couple j'ai pas envie de donner un
modèle à mes enfants de maman qui
parlent pas qu'ils aient pas gai tout ça
lorsque je suis je suis foncièrement gay
mais voilà moi pour moi le confinement
c'est du pain bénit le masque tout ça
les gens ne touchent pas il ya eu tous
faim sauf que c'est du pain bénit sauf
qu'avec les enfants à la maison continue
avec moi assurez-vous façon de parler
voilà bien sûr pour les téléspectateurs
c'est que vous dans votre cas c'est vrai
que vous vous êtes toujours dans dans
notre monde en fait vous arrivé là
oui en fait est de plus en plus en fait
surtout depuis mon diagnostic qui a été
donc un long processus va commencer en
2012 quand j'étais au chômage et que
j'ai eu du temps pour me reposer mois en
question c'était j'ai fait des tests un
peu sur internet qui disait que j'étais
super autistes alors j'ai fait part à
mon mari qui était qu'il n'était pas du
tout et en fait j'ai commencé à prendre
les rendez-vous mais c'est quand même
deux ans avant d'obtenir un rendez-vous
à l'hôpital pas mais juste le dico
j'entends votre votre témoignage est et
je pense que les téléspectateurs concept
d'un logement dal impression vous vous
étiez très heureuse
retenons dès que vous avez décidé de
vous faire diagnostiquer de changer pour
pour votre famille pour votre mari pour
les autres surtout j'ai surtout les
baissiers d1
quand je me suis retrouvé en confinement
donc je vais commencer en 2012 ça n'a
pas abouti et je me suis finalement que
ça changera dans ma vie bien sûr on voit
que vous êtes d'agde de sigur mars 2020
qui corrige donc j'ai été diagnostiquée
effectivement pendant comportement
j'ai juste eu ni blessés moment j'ai du
temps je vais refaire ce processus là et
quand on m'a dit que l'hôpital c'était
deux ans d'attenté que de toute façon
pas que j'arrive avec un papier d'un
psychologue ou un psychiatre disent que
les premiers tests ont montré que
j'étais sûrement autistes donc voilà
donc je suis passé par le centre
ressource autisme d'île de france qui
m'a adressée à une psychologue qui
m'adresser à nos psychiatres qui met
juste de s'installer qui est spécialiste
christmas père gars j'ai fait des tonnes
de tests voilà mais ça allait très
rapidement et m'a recruté achats été
déclaré dans l'ancien dans
l'enchaînement joussot est en fait je
les fais ce que je me suis dit voilà en
plus je me suis retrouvé au chômage fin
juillet licenciement économique
et là je me suis dit 1 40 ans passés il
ya plus de raison que ce soit toujours
toi qui soit dans l'adaptation est temps
que ton employeur ou ton entourage aussi
soit dans l'adaptation est donc j'ai
cherché un employeur un emploi je suis
responsable communication quand même
depuis un paquet d'années parce que
c'est une quantité intéressante dont
claude on voit maintenant je travaille
alors je vais venir mais aussi cinq
responsables communication depuis très
longtemps parce que c'est une façon pour
moi de deux motos rééduquer sachant que
l'autisme n'est pas une maladie ça ne se
soigne pas n'y a pas de médicaments qui
soignent à l'autisme donc très sévère
qui peut nécessiter une certaine
médication pour calmer certains troubles
à l'autisme asperger qui voilà qui ne
nécessite aucune médication sauf
éventuellement un état anxieux nous et
donc je suis dit j'ai envie de trouver
un job ou mon patron michael a
naturellement avec bienveillance
donc j'ai commencé à travailler mon
profil sur linkedin sur les réseaux
sociaux en intégrant des gros points
intègre en voyant des en mettant en
contact avec pas mal de monde
du monde du handicap et j'ai envoyé j'ai
monté aussi ma chaîne youtube pour
expliquer c'est en pleine semaine est ce
ce ph donc la semaine pour l'emploi des
personnes handicapées
j'ai fait ma grand mythen jeu ma petite
chaîne youtube pour expliquer en
employer des gens en situation de
handicap pas que les autistes mais
forcément je parle de moi en fin de mon
cas c'est bon c'est pas si pas si
compliqué que ça en fait ça nécessite
pas forcément des tonnes d'adaptation et
preuves à l'appui en janvier février
j'ai envoyé mon cv un ménisque en clair
qui est présidente fondatrice de
l'association du club des six qui est
une association qui créent des habitats
inclusif sous forme de colocation pour
sip aux locataires qu'ils livrent chacun
donc en situation de handicap qui vivent
en colocation comme comme des colloques
je vais voir tout ça et avec leurs
spécificités chacun il se cooptent les
uns les autres ils font leur période
d'essai pour voir si ceux placés les uns
des autres et contribue technicien lors
secourir près j'ai envoyé mon cv à
maylis mois n'a pas répondu à tout de
suite c'est personne qui est très occupé
et très sollicités pour la bonne cause
et de trois jours après j'ai reçu un
appel de la rh qui qui me disaient que
mon cv avait fait mouche
donc j'ai eu au téléphone on a passé une
heure et jeudi mais vous vous avez vu je
porte un handicap
maintenant j'ai envie l'annoncé est donc
ça va nécessiter peut-être quelques
adaptations a dit mais bien sûr pas de
problème donc on s'est rencontrés on
s'est vus on sait plus j'ai rencontré
maëlys dans la foulée et et voilà je
suis dans tous ses tours aujourd'hui sur
la pression chez hyper heureuse
l'arctique c'est parce que déjà mon
employeur à ma prise avec les
spécificités avec des adaptations lors
je suis hanté l'état travaille trois
jours par semaine pas que cogeco vide
aussi parce que ça permet de me
ressourcer de me recentrer une journée
entière est au rendez vous ça me laisse
complètement sur le pavé le soir quand
je rentre c'est compliqué nerveusement
le métro tout ça enfin j'ose même pas
sortir ma carte handicapés pour qu'on me
laisse une place alors que voilà jeu
c'est un handicap invisible donc la
seule fois où je vous ai demandé parce
que la dame a laissé son caddie je fais
une prendre un pain donc voilà donc
voila et les employeurs donc le club des
six a tout simplement proposé
spontanément de m'équiper
informatiquement la maison m'a demandé
de quoi j'avais besoin d'un bureau on
est dans des petits bureaux partagés et
je vois que je pense que ça participe a
aussi une dynamique des équipes qui est
très inclusive
je pense que toutes les personnes qui
travaillent avec moi sont des personnes
très belle personnalité et c'est ce qui
me fait c'est l'adn du club des six en
fait on travaille pas là par hasard
c'est un élément dans l'inclusion
mais je vois je pense que quand je suis
là ils font encore plus l'effort de
parler moins fort de sortir du bureau
pour passer leur colle parce que j'ai du
mal à me concentrer quand il ya vraiment
trop de surstimulation la vie en tout
cas ces cerveaux témoignages et c'est
vrai que je la sens heureuse et là ni
vous avez vu quand elle part difficile
de l'arrêter alors et puyal aurait pu
faire toutes les missions je fais une
salière passer un casting pour apprendre
à placer margot laffite mais en fait non
on va voir on va voir il faut devenir un
canal chez les fans de formule 1 va voir
on va voir ce qu'on peut faire
je demanderai à pierre gasly s'il peut
vous faire vous pouvez aller le voir un
jour
voilà qui est un pote et que j'embrasse
d'ailleurs on verra pas si je vous
inviterai peut-être j'irai peut-être
compris de france a fait dire à sophie
gens armés c'est vrai en juin on va très
bien sophie c'est demain donc le 2 avril
ce sera la journée mondiale de
sensibilisation à l'autisme
qu'est ce que vous avez à dire aux
téléspectateurs qu'ils connaissent mal
ne rien se sent handicapant exactement
parce que d'abord il est invisible
depuis parce que ça on appelle ça le
trouble du spectre de l'autisme et ça
veut bien dire ce que ça veut dire ça va
vraiment un autisme sévère alors pour
vous faire courser par normes
le film hors norme je sais pas le jury
avait vu jusqu'à l' autisme de haut
niveau c'est plutôt reinmann donc vous
voyez qu'on a un spectre très large et
donc des besoins extrêmement variés mais
pour revenir juste au club des 6 c'est
vraiment quelque chose de formidable
j'étais avec brigitte macron tout à
l'heure parce qu'elle est venue visiter
ce club des 6 où il ya du aussi
bojic macro tout à l'heure et dans
lesquelles bernard tout le temps mais
c'est brigitte m'a dit qu'on était avec
les jeunes surtout qui est là mais c'est
sûr que leur ai pas marre de se taper le
vieux a donc visité les jeunes qui
commencent à cet avantage au logement
c'est ça ça avance maintenant on est
plus ou tout le foyer collectif ou tout
seul chez soi on peut être en coloc la
coloc ça parle aux téléspectateurs ces
jeunes et son colloque et sont autistes
ils sont trisomiques et 100 avec un
service d'accompagnement et y vivent
chez eux mais je suis d'origine
alimentaire
le handicap c'est c'est que c'est
quelque chose qui compte énormément pour
l origine notre